yeah again the questions are come in
there's going to be randomly picked and
we're going to give away a 30 minute
call with me to the to the winner and
then three other windows are going to
get the entrepreneur heroes trading
cards so make sure you ask your
questions and also highlighted a lot of
thinking before this webinar about how
we can do more to help entrepreneurs and
help people to get people to keep going
and to talk to actually implement the
think you're talking about and to
connect them with us as well as other
entrepreneurs and so we're thinking
about creating a membership site that we
wanted to get your feedback on so we
really appreciate if you like this
webinar if you like the last one on
selecting newsletters and everything
I've really appreciated you could take a
couple minutes now or after the webinar
just to go to this address here that
we've listed to fill out a couple
questions we really value your opinions
on that so i'll leave this slide up and
if you guys have questions pump them out
and we'll try to answer them as best we
can so far all over to you yes and you
know if you have any questions to you
know future questions that's all we
could be back to the more that we find
out like what you need especially for
this membership site the more we can
help so sojourner says i'm there if you
make a membership site thank you for
joining ok if anybody has any questions
please type them into the question box I
have a few that have already happened
and I put them into a word doc so or
read as I have a lot of passion however
I don't know I don't know how you know
what to do when you have so many
passions of and how do you have you
figured out how to narrow it down what I
would try to do if you can if you really
feel strongly about it is try to combine
them is that something that a lot of
other people won't be able to copy so
whatever your you know say top two
passions are try to put them together
and embrace the genius of the end and
instead of thinking about this or this
try to find a way to put them together
and that will be a great way to help you
stand out from everybody else in your
market if you're thinking about idea is
that you may be exciting but you're not
quite sure if you want to follow it or
not the test that I usually like to do
is see how much I'm willing to work on
it so if you have your your list of ten
different ideas that you could
potentially work on devote some time to
doing a little bit of research on it so
maybe it's some web research but I'd
also try to set a goal of actually going
to a library or bookstore to do some
research on and see if you actually
follow through on it you'll find that
some we follow through on and some you
want you want to take that trip and sure
you can find all the information
probably online you can find in the
bookstore but it's that process of
investing the time energy to go out and
do it that you'll see a little challenge
your equipment level if you're really
going to have success in it or not if
you're not willing to go to the
bookstore the research about your
business idea chances are you're
probably not going to have a huge
success on that idea and they're from
there I just narrow it down to see where
did I spend my most time which it is
that I spend the most time researching
and where was I most excited about
that's what you want to eventually
narrow yourself down to and if you do
end up with with two different ideas
again see if you can combine them into
one awesome idea that combines multiple
passions and I'll help separate you from
a lot of your competition good bill of
ask you know what service type jobs look
promising in faith market do you see any
trend step I don't know if I can give
you a macro tryna I don't think that's
necessarily the right way to look at
things with all due respect to bills
question because and I think it's a very
common one when you're looking at
analyzing what you should start I always
start around a passion that I have
that's where you should start not around
looking for pain and hopefully you have
the passion you consult you don't want
to just chase the dollars because when
you do I can say here are the top 10
industries that are happening like now
services and you can go and pick up
magazines and newspapers that will tell
you that but going into that business
just because you think you can make
money is not the way to do it I'd rather
go and find something that makes me
really excited and I feel like an offer
a lot of value to my customers and then
go out and try to find customers who
have a specific pain point that I can
help solve your business will change as
you start working with customers and
build around their challenges whatever
it service lead into but i would i would
flip it on its head and go that route
instead of just trying to pick an
industry that i know nothing about or
may know a little bit about but I'm not
really excited about just because i
think it's growing and has an
opportunity yeah uh Carol asked you
suggest not looking for venture funding
to start up instead wait until you've
started and have some earnings show
absolutely and this is coming from the
venture capitalists I would try to if
possible not go for venture capital at
all but if you really need it then
expansion money is the easiest type of
money to raise so that means you've
already shown that you can bring in some
customers and you're making a little bit
of money they don't want to they don't
expect you to be making a huge amount of
money if you were if you were a hugely
successful you wouldn't be going to them
for extra money right but they want to
see that somebody will buy your product
ninety-five percent of the company
submitted a business fine to us had no
traction they had no customers they just
had an idea and so you're competing with
everybody else who just has an idea the
companies who got our attention with the
ones who already had a little bit of
sales they had a little bit of a mention
team in place and it looked like they
had some momentum already going for them
so you want to be able to do that to
increase your chances of getting any
kind of investigators venture capital or
a bank loan or you know angel investor
whatever it is surely has some momentum
the other benefit is you'll get a much
better evaluation the more you can
reduce the risk at the start a startup
business is very risk
you believe in yourself but not a lot of
other people are going to believe
yourself let alone the venture capital
who venture capitalist who doesn't know
you at all so if they were going to give
you some money they would kill you on
the evaluation because there's no track
record but if you can go in and show
them that you already have some
customers and you're already making a
little bit of money may not be
profitable you won't be raking it in yet
but you have some momentum behind you
then you'll get a much better valuations
you get the same money you need but they
won't take as much of your business but
I would also think about you know do you
really need to get venture cap or not
because when you do go after funding
that becomes almost a full time job
which takes you away from you and
actually do things to run and operate
this is so if it is needed definitely go
out and try to get customers and build
momentum before bill also wanted to know
he loved the quotes if you have them on
your website somewhere we are recording
this and we were trying to get it up on
YouTube for you so you know that's
always a possibility but I don't know if
you keep these quotes anywhere Evan yeah
I do on now this is a selection so we
have on our site we have the largest
selection of a massage from our story so
a long way that comes a ton of quotes on
my site not on the homepage for any
inside pages at the top you'll see a
link that says quotes and I pick my top
ten boats that I really enjoy that I
find help me with my business and then
under there a whole bunch of famous
entrepreneur quotes that I find
inspiring as well and a lot of these are
mentioned here too and then for any of
these famous entrepreneurs we've done a
profile on our website and there's a
whole page of their best quotes as well
do you guys can check out but we will be
recording or we are recording this who
and then we will be releasing it so as
long as you guys pay attention to the
newsletter email I guess you'll see some
of the updates about when we reserve
unit
um the joiner asks what's the best way
to keep himself accountable would you
recommend as a good kick in the twitch
to keep your business hmm that's a good
one I do a couple things first is with
my mastermind groups we have an annual
goal that we set as usually it has to be
a numeric goal so most people pick a
revenue goal but has to be something
numeric so it's not I want to feel good
about my business it's I want to hit XYZ
something measurable every month and
they help keep you know me accountable
and I help them accountable to every
every month when we have our meeting so
that helps also in our forums online we
do a monthly goal setting that you guys
can participate in to where we say
here's what our goals are for the month
and we try to help you know hold each
other accountable at the beginning
people may say oh you didn't hit your
goal you know you gotta keep working on
it but if you have the same goals on
there for three months people will start
to get a little harder on you right like
hey what's up you add this goal on here
for three months you haven't done
anything on it so I wouldn't I find by
committing to other people you're more
likely to to follow through on it so
through the mastermind groups and
through the forms and maybe through the
membership site you know put that put
that down as an idea that would be a
great option too but when you involve
other people you more likely to follow
through the other thing I find that
sometimes I think it's pretty common you
put down goals that are aspirational
that you want to get done but for
whatever reason you're not doing it and
and sometimes it doesn't mean you should
do it often it means you just you should
cut it and focus on something else a lot
of times and you make put a goal down
you you listen to me say hey that was a
great idea haven't had and then you just
whatever really don't think it's going
to fit your business having something
there for three months or six months
that you don't do sometimes it means you
shouldn't do it and you should move on
to something else that you are a little
bit more excited
you can only force yourself to do
something or so long so you have to end
up buying it back in something that
you're really passionate about but I
think the biggest kick in the pants
exigent ass comes from the mass my group
or people know me and I've stated my
goals and and that makes you a little
vulnerable to say you're gonna do
something that you're hoping you can do
but you're not a hundred percent is
going to have happen because a lot of
the factors may be outside your control
but having those people there just to
know say hey you know you didn't get
this thing done we have a wee phone call
between some of the members that that
kind of makes you want to keep going cuz
you know you're gonna meet them in a
week on the phone or in a month in the
meeting and you wanna you want to look
good and say hey I got this done and not
not face to fire every time you go I
find that's the biggest up for me oh oh
it's three o'clock eastern and we
probably should pick these winners
because probably some people have to
leave I picked four winners i hope i can
pick any people from who won last time
but if so then you had a good really
good question so i went with you a bill
helm won a free half hour call with evan
great yeah so please bill email Evan at
Evan Carmichael calm and packs of cards
Gary Bartlett Ron Bartlett and Heather
chernof's they all did a fantastic job
oh sorry Ron Gibson was the number two
Gary Bartlett Ron Gibson I miss wrote
that and Heather chernofsky very job
everybody right sorry with my email up
on the on the slide there if you guys an
email and if you had a question I didn't
get to our know there's a whole bunch of
questions shoot me an email i'll try to
answer quickly to for you and we're
thinking about our next one to the topic
is growing your business building the
marketing machine so getting me on the
startup stage now really growing a
business and I've set a tenant update I
say Canada because I haven't told Carl
about our date hopefully September 13th
works for you
ty that's the tender that they still
keep you guys updated and please if you
can I would really like to keep back
here to about the google doc and the
potential membership site so thank you
and thank you carl to first for helping
to set this on them oh it's great i
always learn a lot too and these
questions were fantastic i really loved
how active everybody was and evan he did
a fantastic job once again alright well
thanks guys and i look forward to
hearing your emails and send me those
pitches i want to read them and give you
some feedback to all right everybody
have a great day and thanks so much for
joining us bye
you